e
[Musique]
ici commence l'histoire du doubs et de
la loue une curieuse histoire fêtes de
combes et de platon de gouffres de
grottes et de falaises mais elle est
avant tout une histoire dont bien sûr de
pluie ou de neige celles qui tombent
parfois en abondance sur la montagne
loki avec la roche calcaire a marqué
avec tant de force les paysages du
massif jurassien à peine réunie sous
forme de ruisseaux celle-là a parfois un
très étrange destin qui lui fait suivre
des chemins pour le moins inhabituel
appel irrésistible des couches profondes
du calcaire de ses fractures de ses
failles et de leur labyrinthe insondable
un seul mot résume cet univers étrange
le cas partout des centaines de
kilomètres de galeries de ce type
transperce le sous sol une partie des
eaux issues de chaque bassin versant
situé plus haut à la surface s'ils
réunissent et circule rapidement l'autre
partie des eaux souterraines jurassienne
un parcours différent plus lent plus
cacher elle se stockent dans les
profondeur insoupçonnée de certaines
galeries noyer mais surtout dans les
punchs des millions de micro porosité
des couches de calcaire
elle forme des réserves qui s'écouleront
des semaines ou des mois plus tard
alimentant les rivières en période
d'étiage ici se préparer se joue d'une
certaine façon l'avenir de la plupart
des rivières franc comtoise
mais ici n'est tout d'abord le doubs
retour de l'eau à la lumière et à la vie
à près de sombre et mystérieux trajet
aux limites encore inexploré et départ
pour un nouveau voyage infiniment plus
riche et varié
à 950 mètres d'altitude été comme hiver
la première partie du cours du doubs
épouse paresseusement le val de mouthe
sous lui
le calcaire et ses galeries profondes
sont toujours là mais recouvert cette
fois par des dépôts imperméable seul
essai en particulier par les derniers
glaciers disparu il ya tout juste quinze
mille ans
après 15 kilomètres de méandres
paresseux une première étape
sauf road où ils se font pour un instant
et avec nonchalance dans le lac de saint
point avant de poursuivre plus tard sa
jeune route
au delà de pontarlier n'ont d'ailleurs
sans dissimuler l'un de ses premiers
secrets
ledoux qui s'écoule dans le paysage dans
la vallée est une rivière un peu
particulière parce qu'elle va perdre une
partie de son nom sur une dizaine de
kilomètres
surtout dans la région dach sont à laval
de pontarlier
elle a une partie de son débit qui va
s'infiltrer dans le sous sol et qui va
aller alimenter la source de la loue
donc c'est dans cette région clé du
système du doubs et de la loue que
s'organisent en quelque sorte la
relation entre les deux rivières les
eaux qui sortent à la source de la loue
sont des eaux qui ont déjà eu une
histoire parcours dans le doubs pour
autant c'est resté très longtemps un
mystère et puis c'est tout à fait
fortuitement à l'occasion d'un incendie
célèbre celle incendies des usines
pernaut de la distillerie pernaut à
pontarlier en 1900 on n'a rien trouvé de
mieux à l'époque la distillerie étant au
bord du doubs et bien d'évacuer ses
stocks d'absinthe directement dans le
doubs et en quelques heures on a évacué
des mètres cubes des mètres cubes
d'absinthe
évidemment le doubs a été largement
chargé d'absinthe est la grande surprise
c'est que 48 heures après l incendie
on a constaté que la halle où sont tes
l'absinthe que la loue prenait une
couleur d'absinthe dans la partie haute
de son cours et les gens de la vallée de
la loue ont eu le plaisir à ce moment là
d'avoir accès directement à une boisson
délivré gracieusement par la rivière et
ça a été une grande surprise
ça a été une grande surprise parce que
c'est la première fois en 1901
ben qu'on constatait réellement qu'il y
avait une connexion hydraulique entre le
doubs à l'amont et la loue à laval
[Musique]
trois cents mètres plus bas que les
pertes d'arçons et après 20 kilomètres
de mystérieux parcours à travers
l'épaisseur des roches calcaires retour
à l'air libre pour les eaux du doubs
augmentées de celles issues des réserves
karstique les effluves d'absinthe du
passé sont loin mais la résurgence de la
loue et toujours à sa place
naissance d'une nouvelle rivière fillon
ne peut plus naturel en quelque sorte
d'un très jeune géniteurs et des malices
de la géologie
voici le départ d'une aventure longue de
plus de 120 km
[Musique]
là
les premiers mètres de la vie à l'air
libre sont discrets en chasser au plus
profond des gorges de noailles sous le
couvert danse des arbres il faudra halal
ou parcourir plus de 4km détroit
méandres entaillé dans le calcaire de sa
naissance
avant de s'étaler véritablement au
soleil et devenir la rivière
enchanteresse celles dont la réputation
s'est déployée depuis des décennies bien
au-delà des frontières durant des
siècles des millénaires lahlou a été
dopée sûrs de truites et ombres par
milliers de myriad d'insectes aquatiques
puis il ya plus de quinze ans déjà
vainqueur que signent à peine
perceptible les premières alertes dont
quelques amoureux de la rivière avait
très tôt capter l'importance jusqu'au
désastre depuis longtemps pressenti des
cadavres de poissons flottaient sur la
surface de la rivière détruites mort du
team de mycoses il ne s'agit pas
seulement de simples mycoses ou maladie
suis tout frais mais d'une prolifération
de cyanobactéries
pas question donc d'ignorer les causes
des diverses pollutions épandages de
lisier rejets industriels et domestiques
ce sont les eaux usées qui sont rejetés
directement dans les lieux naturels
j'ai péché pendant 30 ans aujourd'hui je
pèche plus parce que c'est la rivière
étant un état déplorable
un enterrement à ornans courbet en a
fait l'un de ses plus célèbres tableaux
eu un acte symbolique un cri d'alarmé
face à la pollution de la loue depuis un
mois son cahier de réservations se
vident les français mais aussi pour
moitié des groupes de pêcheurs venus des
etats-unis du japon d'australie et de
nouvelle zélande
d'après le collectif pour la halle où
l'état ne respecte pas la directive
européenne sur l'eau et nous allons vers
l'europe où on sait que notre plainte va
être entendu et que à la une chance
d'avoir des répercussions sur l'état
français pour que les mesures
nécessaires indispensables aurait déjà
dû être soit prise
que s'est il passé au printemps 2010
puis ensuite en 2011 de brutales
mortalité de truites et des ombres sont
apparus doublé d'un développement
simultané de cyanobactéries toxiques sur
le fond de la rivière
les polluants à l'origine de cette
hécatombe sont multiples mais le rôle
précis de chacun
difficile à cerner leurs interactions
sont en effet nombreuses mais les faits
sont là
indiscutable des seuils ont été
dépassées depuis des décennies la
qualité de l'eau et des habitats de la
loue se sont dégradées inexorablement
fragilisant la santé des peuplements
piscicoles et de l'ensemble de
l'écosystème que représente la rivière
très vite les regards se sont tournés
d'abord vers des pollutions d'origine
agricole mais aussi domestique qui n'ont
cessé de se développer au fil de la
croissance démographique et économique
malgré les traitements dont elles
doivent normalement faire l'objet
le polonais nitrates à plusieurs sources
1 on va pas s'amuser à pointer du doigt
le milieu agricole ou le milieu urbain
toujours éthiques
ces nitrates qu'ils soient d'origine
agricole ou urbaines sont des éléments
qui vont participer à la délibération du
milieu là où la composante phosphate
intervient donc on a les deux éléments
les deux nutriments qui vont faire du
grand développement photosynthétiques
c'est là dessus qu'il va falloir jouer
puisque les deux éléments mélanger et
bien en fait sont des véritables terreau
pour faire exploser en fait ces
développements à al gore et qui génère
ce fameux désordre cet étouffement fait
des habitats et l'étouffement donc des
substrats de cette magnifique rivière
première cause effet connu donc mais
manquerait-il des contraintes plus
fortes à leur égard il faut qu'il ait
d'abord des réglementations spécifiques
qui soit adaptée à la réalité des
problèmes écologiques faut se souvenir
que la réglementation a supprimé les
phosphates dans les produits pour laver
le linge mais les a pas supprimées
pendant les produits pour la vaisselle
soit que vaisselle à la main ou machine
donc il faut qu'il y ait une
interdiction d'utilisation des
phosphates il faut absolument tordre le
bras aux industriels qui refusent
d'appliquer ça il ya plein d'autres pays
en europe qui l'ont appliquée pourquoi
la france n'applique pas cette
disposition qui coûtent pas cher du tout
les mots très violents dont souffre la
loue et d'autres rivières franc comtoise
nous fait revenir à l'origine de leur
eau à leur passage dans le calcaire aux
cartes ici malheureusement les polluants
de l'eau issue de la surface ne sont pas
ou sont très peu dégradée filtré avant
de ressortir à l'air libre
contrairement à ce qui se passe dans
d'autres sous sol fait de sédiments
comme les sables et graviers par exemple
ainsi certaines sources certaine
résurgence peuvent elles être pollué dès
l'origine mais revenons à l'air libre et
à la loue ou d'autres facteurs
interviennent de façon forte dans les
désordres passées et actuelles
mais élément nouveau variations du
climat modifications climatiques
on a effectivement donc des
réchauffements réchauffement de l'eau
bien sûr tout affect avec des grandes
modifications de température voire de
débit en termes de volume
il tombe à peu près toujours le même
volume d'eau mais d'une manière beaucoup
plus saccadé tout le monde a bien vu
en fait les arrivées des crues qui sont
beaucoup plus violente que quand il ya
50 ans les étiages qui sont beaucoup
plus prononcé donc on voit véritablement
l'ensemble de ces variations de débit
associé à segment des augmentations de
température bien en fait vont jouer en
défaveur du milieu piscicole
face à cette situation très préoccupante
des solutions existent mais elles
impliquent des choix radicaux dans la
manière de concilier économie et
préservation de l'environnement
la feuille de route elle est clairement
établie il va falloir clairement qu'on
se dise est-ce qu'on développe les
filières agricoles avec une augmentation
du cheptel est que l'abandon de l'apag
tous comme cela est ce que l'on a comme
volonté en fait de garder une rivière de
qualité ou de partir sur un
développement à outrance de toutes les
activités sur le bassin versant et sas
avait un choix politique je pense qu'il
ya de la place à la fois pour ses
activités en les gérant d'une manière
assez fine et en affinant l'ensemble des
traitements l'ensemble des rejets et
l'ensemble de l'évolution des filières
2012 a été une année de répit apparent
durant laquelle la rivière n'a pas subi
de nouvelles pertes malgré l'état
préoccupant de son lit autour d'elle la
mobilisation de l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés est toujours aussi forte
mêlant à la fois élus associations
scientifiques et représentants de l'état
10 mais nous sommes là pour nous
mobiliser pour partager avec vraiment je
crois le seul objectif de nous organiser
pour une action efficace et reese lure
c'est en bassin versant qui est
vulnérable de par sa nature karstique
on s'est posé beaucoup d'interrogations
pendant cette expertise sur les charges
aux micropolluants qu'ils soient
d'origine industrie
elle d'origine agricole ou d'origine
domestique le phosphore même si ce n'est
pas exclusif mais le phosphore provient
quand même beaucoup des rejets
domestiques il s'agit poursuit avec le
monde agricole depuis des années
beaucoup de choses ont déjà été faites
pour protéger cette rivière beaucoup
d'énergie et de moyens ont été dépensés
dans un passé récent
ceux-ci ont répondu à une véritable
nécessité
regardez dégradation constante dont la
loue faisait l'objet depuis des années
qu'ils vont dire je crois que ce que ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est l'aspect multi
factorielle des choses mais l'évidence
est là
la situation reste très précaire les
conclusions des assises de la loue ont
été clairs et ont fait l'unanimité des
participants la nécessité de redoubler
d'efforts s'imposent plus que jamais
avec celle d'agir vite et fortement sur
les pollutions les mieux identifier y
compris on l'a évoqué avec les deux
sénateurs présents
le temps de l'action est venu mais le
temps de réaction des structures
administratives techniques et politiques
sera-t-il en véritable adéquation avec
l'urgence de la situation sur le terrain
car si l'année 2012 n'a pas vu de
mortalité forte de truites ou dhombres
la prolifération des algues et le
colmatage du fonds sont toujours à
l'ordre du jour sur une bonne partie du
cours de la rivière
[Musique]
visiblement seule une partie des
populations initiale de truites et
ombres ont été épargnés et parviennent
encore à trouver en surface ou sur le
fond les quelques larves aux insectes
adultes nécessaires à leur subsistance
mais pour évaluer avec précision
l'impact réel des pollutions
il a fallu mettre en place une opération
de pêche électrique de très grande
ampleur
celle ci a eu lieu durant l'été 2012
répétés sur plusieurs points tout au
long du cours de la loue entre moutier
et clairons
les résultats de cette opération sont
malheureusement très parlants en amont
ornant le peuplement piscicole et
d'environ 60% inférieur au potentiel
normal de la rivière mais en aval de
cette ville la situation est plus
préoccupante encore seul reste environ
un cinquième de la population d'origine
l'urgence est donc au rétablissement
rapide de la qualité de l'eau et des
habitats de la loue qui lui permettront
de retrouver sa richesse initial la
tâche est de taille et demandent des
volontés des moyens ambitieux ainsi
qu'une prise de conscience collective
forte eux seuls permettront le retour
des trésors de la rivière truites et
ombres bien sûr mais également
l'ensemble du petit peuple de l'eau les
perles et les éphémères par exemple où
les loges et les chabot pour les plus
connus d'entre eux
il
mais au delà des poissons la communauté
vivante de la rivière inclut également
d'autres espèces elle aussi extrêmement
dépendante de la qualité de l'eau et de
la faune d'insectes qui s'y développe le
cincle plongeur en est un exemple
car chaque jour il met les larves
d'éphémères de pelle ou de freegan à son
menu
alors même si l'avenir reste
terriblement incertain espérons donc
revoir le plus vite possible
les vols des innombrables insectes en
parade à la surface et en même temps
l'image devenu si rare de leurs
prédateurs habituel en pleine chasse
[Musique]
retour sur le court du doubs 30 km après
les pertes d'arçons au delà de morteau
il file vers le nord dans des paysages
similaires à ceux de la haute vallée de
la loue en délimitant par ses gorges la
frontière franco suisse
lui aussi a connu les mêmes dommages que
la loue en 2010 et 2011 en 2012
persistait encore au milieu de l'été de
lourdes perturbations de l'état de l'eau
leur traduction visuelle laissé peu de
doutes sur l'origine d'une pollution
dans laquelle nitrates et phosphates
était sans doute une fois de plus au
rendez vous
mais au delà des atteintes liés à
différents effluents chimiques le doubs
franco-suisse suit également d'autres
perturbations
celles ci sont liées à l'existence d'un
certain nombre de barrages
hydroélectriques dont l'exploitation
nécessite le turbinage parfois brutales
des réserves d'eau accumulées en amont
les conséquences de ces mouvements d'eau
sont évidemment très forte sur l'état et
la survie des peuplements de poissons et
de la petite faune de la rivière mais il
pose également de façon très aigu la
difficile coexistence entre une activité
humaine en développement constant la
production d'énergie dont elle a besoin
et le maintien d'un milieu naturel de
qualité lui aussi gage d'une activité
économique importante liées à la pêche
poursuivons plus loin encore le voyage
pour retrouver le doubs dans son cours
moyen à 240 mètres d'altitude environ
nous sommes en aval de baume les dames
ici les atteintes actuelle à la qualité
de l'eau et des populations piscicoles
du doubs franco-suisse et de la haute
loue trouve un écho particulièrement
frappant si l'on remonte le temps
jusqu'au début des années 70
nous sommes sur les bords du doubs entre
montbéliard et besançon ici il ya
quelques années c'était le paradis des
pêcheurs ils accourent et de suisse de
belgique et même d'angleterre
car dans les eaux du doubs et de ses
affluents sur 900 km ont capturé en
quantité détruit des brochets des
perches des gardons aujourd'hui dans ces
eaux polluées le poisson se raréfient et
celui qu'on attrape pas si mauvais goût
qu'on est obligé de le rejeter
depuis ma tendre et jeunesse le ps aux
emprunts le doubs mais depuis deux ans
il n'est plus intéressant de prendre du
poisson les hôtels vous refuse le
poisson les amis n'en veulent plus
manger c'est pas du tout intéressant
d'ailleurs santé cette mousse ils
proviennent de la rivière empoisonne
elles sont le gasoil les vieilles villes
tout ce que vous voulez qu'ils polluent
le douce et les automobiles peugeot
qu'est ce qui vous permet de dire ça je
connais le problème il est en point
certains produits est trop mou et le
décapage de leur carrosserie
vous pensez que ce produit qui donne
deux associés
peugeot en fr mauvaise réputation il ya
quelques semaines lusine a été condamné
par le tribunal de montbéliard pour
avoir déversé dans la rivière des huiles
de vidange une mini marée noire qui a
tué les poissons sur plusieurs
kilomètres mais ce n'était qu'une
escarmouche un épisode de la bataille
qui met aux prises les pollueurs
l'administration et les associations de
défense celle-ci ne proteste pas
seulement contre les pollutions
accidentelles
elle dénonce une pollution générale
permanente et elle mobilise pour sauver
leurs rivières
mais voici un autre accusé de taille la
papeterie laroche est sympa à novillars
400 ouvriers y fabrique 68 kg de papier
par jour elle rejette aussi chaque jour
15 à 20 millions de litres d'eau quels
déchets y at-il dans cette eau les
autres essentiellement des matières
organiques
ces deux-là dinning de dubois qui a été
dissoute au cours de la cuisson
effectivement si nous rejetons beaucoup
de matière beaucoup d'oxygène seront
absorbées et d'oxygène restant pour les
passants ne viendrait pas suffisant de
temps un pollueur conscient très
conscient et à l'heure actuelle il se
trouve sur le bureau de monsieur poujade
tout un plan que nous appelons le plan
de sauvetage du doubs ce plan de
sauvetage est encore secret il
s'étendrait sur une douzaine d'années et
coûterait 180 millions la longueur de
ces délais l'énormité des dépenses
témoigne avec éloquence s'il faut tant
d'années tant d'argent pour trouver le
doubs c'est que la rivière est vraiment
à l'agonie comment est ce que vous
comptez faire participer la population
et éventuellement les associations qui
défendent le dos à cette action de
sauvetage
je suis ravi de constater qu'il ya des
associations qui qui tire la sonnette
d'alarmé car ils m'aident
il m'aide à créer une une ambiance
psychologique et je dois dire que déjà
cette ce climat secret car de plus en
plus les industries indiennes coopératif
oui pour que les pollueurs deviennent
coopératifs il faut que les citoyens se
fâche
sur ce point la sphère du doubs est
exemplaire depuis dix ans envoyé se
dégrader la rivière les pêcheurs
protestaient en ne les écoutez guerre le
jour ils se sont groupés en une
puissante association
le jour ils ont fait appel aux
scientifiques le jour ils ont traîné les
pollueurs devant les tribunaux alors
tout a commencé à changer
la bataille pour le doubs durera douze
ans ce sera un test
on verra si l'on continue à se payer de
mots ou s'il en est vraiment décidé à
préserver ce bien collectif qu'est l'eau
de nos rivières
nous y reviendrons
[Musique]
quarante années plus tard c'est archives
nous parle encore avec toute sa force
les enjeux les acteurs et le ressort de
la pièce qui s'est joué hier ne sont ils
pas d'une certaine façon profondément
similaires à ceux d'aujourd'hui
à l'heure actuelle dans la partie
moyenne de son cours le doubs a retrouvé
un état relativement satisfaisant des
années de combat et de lente prise de
conscience ont en effet abouti à une
réglementation stricte pour le
traitement avant rejet des effluents
industriels et domestiques sans oublier
la capacité d'auto épuration du doubs
d'autant plus forte que la rivière a
atteint ici une taille et une dimension
importante
cependant le cours d'eau restent
toujours touchés par ces agressions
ancien une partie des polluants de cette
sinistre époque sont en effet encore
ensevelis dans les sédiments du fond il
contamine encore maintenant certains
poissons dont la consommation est
toujours interdite
retour sur les bords de la loue dans sa
partie inférieure cette fois après sa
sortie des plateaux jurassiens en aval
d'arc et senans la rivière a grandi a
pris de l'ampleur alimenté par les eaux
du lizon de la furieuse et de quelques
rares ruisseau encore en haut ici les
dégâts de la pollution qui a touché la
haute loue ne se sont pas ou peu fait
sentir
pourtant malgré les apparences un oeil
un peu curieux s'étonnera rapidement
l'eau semble de bonne qualité mais il
manque ici quelque chose
il manque de la vie il manque tout
simplement des poissons cela ne sont que
des survivants
ils sont les derniers est maigre témoins
d'une époque où la basse vallée de la
loue comme la partie supérieure de son
cours était le paradis absolu de la
pêche hombre tweets étaient au rendez
vous bien sûr mais également brochet
perche lot en nombre et surtout de
taille respectable plus de 30 espèces
différentes étaient présentes dans la
rivière mais dès les années 1970
le déclin s'est amorcé actuellement
seuls douze à quinze espèces subsistent
dans la basse vallée de la loue dans les
années 1990 on trouvait sur la loue à
part s'est entouré de long de la truite
du togo ce tome doublage on est le
silure était absent depuis 2007 le
silure apparaît et depuis 1999 l'ombre a
disparu la truite a disparu en 2003 la
truite pour se reproduire
elles pourraient trouver des sommes
intéressantes sur la lune mais elle
préfère largement accéder aux petits
affluents de la rivière pour pondre les
truites elles se développent et
rejoignent le cours d'eau mais depuis
les perturbations qu'ils sont cons qui
touche les affluents mauvaise qualité
des eaux destruction des habitats
harcèlement
les truites ne trouve plus les habitats
favorables à leur reproduction
et au bout la truite tend à disparaître
régulièrement et inexorablement sur la
nuque longue c'est une espèce pas très
exigeante en qualité de l'habitat mais
par contre il est très exigeant sur la
température la température de confort
c'est 18 20 degrés 22 degrés ça peut
encore aller pour cette espèce là au
dessus de 22 degrés température l'étal
des poissons meurent et c'est bien ce
qui s'est passé pour l'ombre les
chiffres existence sur l'évolution des
températures de l'eau de la loue depuis
plusieurs décennies sont absolument sans
appel en 73 jean vernon avait calculé
qu'en été sur les 30 jours les plus
chauds on atteignait 17,6 sur par ces
moyennes en 2000 en 1995 on était à 21,4
actuellement on est également à 21,9 22
mai ce qui est le plus remarquable 20 ce
qui est plus inquiétant c'est les max
les maximales de température atteint à
titre d'exemple à parcé on atteint 24
degrés 5h hisser en 2006 j'ai mesuré une
température de 27,5 degrés sur la
gravière de villers j
ça c'est des températures que les
peuplements ne peuvent pas accepter même
des peuplements de rivière- langues
locales
[Musique]
dans le passé de tels excès ponctuelle
de la température de l'eau ne touchait
pas les poissons il était atténuée ou
annulées par des apports d'eau froide et
oxygénées issus des nappes phréatiques
avec laquelle la rivière était en
permanence en contact dans les mortes ou
simplement par le fonds aujourd'hui
cette connexion a complètement disparu
mais alors que s'est-il passé
comment en est on arrivé là l'histoire
commence au moment où l'homme a décidé
de contrôler la loue celle ci en effet
longtemps eu une très mauvaise
réputation durant des siècles elle a
occupé un lit majeur très large dans
lequel elle divaguait selon son humeur
s'est cru formant de nombreux bras
détresse reliés les uns aux autres et
inondant parfois fortement son parcours
cette carte d'état-major datant de 1866
témoignent de l'état initial de la
circulation de l'eau dans la loue qui
allait se trouver bouleversée au fil du
temps
[Musique]
90 ans plus tard les multiples
interventions humaines se traduisirent
en effet par une disparition presque
totale des méandres d'origine enfin en
1966 une dernière phase de travaux est
entreprise
elle a consisté à couper définitivement
les derniers méandres et à rectifier une
fois pour toutes le tracé de la rivière
qui devient alors presque rectiligne
aujourd'hui le résultat de cette
intervention désastreuse et sous nos
yeux
canaliser uniformiser la riviera n'est
plus que l'ombre d'elle-même
certes les enjeux sociétaux de cette
période agricoles en particulier était
infiniment plus forts que ceux liés à
l'environnement
mais ce que les plus ardents défenseurs
de la loue de cette époque avait prédit
c'est maintenant réaliser le scénario
était écrit lait cru par exemple
maintenu dans le carcan dérivant rocher
sont devenus plus brutale et ont vu leur
puissance érosive décupler la rivière
s'est lentement mais sûrement enfoncé
dans son lit parfois de plus de deux
mètres déséquilibrant l'ensemble de son
environnement hydrologique les restes
des anciens bras se sont asséchés tandis
que le niveau des nappes phréatiques
descendait peu à peu
parallèlement en été et parfois dès le
printemps les périodes d'étiage sont
devenus de plus en plus nombreuses plus
longue et plus marqué
[Musique]
des années plus tard quelques opérations
de réaménagement ont tenté de remédier à
une partie de ces dégâts causés par le
recalibrage initial de la rivière des
barrages ont été installés régulièrement
sur le court de la loue il était destiné
à retenir l'eau en amont tout en animant
un peu à laval visuellement le résultat
a pu apparaître au départ relativement
satisfaisant mais peu à peu il s'est
avéré que ces barrages générait d'autres
perturbations particulièrement néfaste
en effet si les chutes provoque une
certaine oxygénation de l'eau sur
quelques dizaines de mètres
la température de celle retenue en amont
immobile sur de grandes distances
atteint rapidement des valeurs très
élevées
d'autre part le courant quasiment nulle
provoque un dépôts d'alluvions fine qui
colmate et stérilisant partie le fond
alors pêcher ou apprendre à pêcher
relève donc maintenant d'une véritable
foi inébranlable en l'avenir même si
d'importantes opérations sur le long
terme comme le contrat de rivière loup
cherche à améliorer sensiblement la
situation car de la richesse initial il
ne reste aujourd'hui qu'une simple
riviera d'agrément ou une qualité d'eau
correct ne permet plus maintenant que le
plaisir de la baignade ou de quelques
randonnées au fil de l'eau pour les plus
courageux mais à côté de la rivière
canalisée et enfoncé dans son lit
subsiste encore quelques restes de la
splendeur passée
alors manière cependant ces reliques
restent avec leur environnement immédiat
des milieux d'un certain intérêt
biologique ou l'amateur de nature peut
encore trouver quelques petits sujet
d'émerveillement
[Applaudissements]
d'autres anciennes mortes sont au
contraire très dégradé elles sont
devenues l'un des enjeux importants du
contrat de rivière en cours depuis
plusieurs années sur les communes de
chissey sur loup et de chambley certains
d'entre eux ont été aménagés pour
permettre leur connexion avec le cours
de la loue et leur redonner vie en
facilitant une éventuelle reconstitution
d'une partie de la faune et de la flore
d'origine d'autres opérations sont en
cours dans ce cadre destiné art-nature
et la rivière il s'agit par exemple de
lui redonner un peu de liberté sur une
portion de son lit en des zorro chant
partiellement une partie de ses rives
mais malgré ses efforts importants le
retour à un état correct des mortes et
du cours de la loi elle-même prendra
sans nul doute beaucoup de temps s'il
doit un jour à devenir
pour avoir une idée du chemin à
parcourir et retrouver le paysage
initial de la loue le plus simple est de
descendre les derniers kilomètres de son
court jusqu en aval de parcelles à
quelques centaines de mètres de son
retour dans les eaux de son géniteur
ici subsistent les restes de ce qui peut
peut-être ressembler à la loue des
années 50 ou 60 une rivière en liberté
aux profondeurs est au courant variés
taillon sa route à son gré dans laquelle
la ligne droite et l'uniformité n'ont
jamais eu leur place
le mot biodiversité et en galvaudé
n'existait évidemment pas à l'époque
pour donner du sens à ce qui était une
évidence quotidienne un milieu riche et
toutes les espèces animales et végétales
qu'il pouvait accueillir et dont
certaines ont depuis longtemps
définitivement disparu
la loutre fait partie de ces fantômes de
la rivière
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui les loutres sont loin mais
une partie du milieu de la confluence
des deux rivières sur la rive droite du
doubs a gardé un intérêt suffisant pour
qu'il soit créé en 1982 la réserve
naturelle du girard ici en retrait de la
rivière la jungle inextricable des
forêts denses de sol parsemé de l'eau
des anciens bras forme encore un milieu
biologiquement très favorable les
habitants permanents ou de passage de
ces lieux ont pour nom balbuzard pêcheur
butor étoilé canard des différentes
espèces ou la rendre gorge bleue celle
ci se laisse parfois voir au printemps
lorsqu'elle défend son territoire pour
beaucoup d'autres je vais tout rossignol
la discrétion est par contre la règle
seule la variété de leurs chants
entremêlées cry et leur présence sur la
rive la réserve englobe également une
gravière régulièrement entretenue par
les crues de la rivière
c'est le royaume des galets et celui
habituel du petit gravelot
plus surprenant par contre les berges de
la confluence de la loue et du doubs ont
vu arriver depuis quelques années déjà
des tranches voyageurs grand amateur des
corses de sol ou de peupliers depuis
quelques années les castors sont en
effet en expansion constante depuis la
vallée du rhône mais il reste cependant
très peu nombreux seules quelques
familles occupent très discrètement
quelques portions des rives de la loue
et du doubs on peut donc considérer que
les castors font maintenant partie de la
faune franc comtoise heureux comme un
castor dans l'eau car ils n'ont vraiment
rien à envier aux poissons pour ce qui
est de nager
[Musique]
ici c'est termine donc le parcours de la
loue après 126 km de voyage et un avenir
chargé de sombres nuages seo rejoignent
celles du doubs pour la partie finale de
son courroux
[Musique]
à
mollet champdivers auto l'an petit noir
ici le doubs est à son apogée dans la
plénitude d'une rivière que l'homme a
laissé un peu vivre malgré de très
anciennes et parfois forte intervention
entre les digues qui assurent la
sécurité des villages et des cultures il
a conservé le droit de rester dans son
lit majeur relativement peu modifié par
comparaison à ce qu'a subi la loue dans
sa partie basse
ici le doubs prend ses aises s'étale de
toute sa puissance façonne encore
parfois ses rives terreuse et joue
toujours avec les galets du fond les
animaux ne s'y trompe pas les plus
méfiants les plus exigeants parfois les
plus étranges d'entre eux ont choisi
cette partie de la rivière et ces
gravières pour y installer leur nid
[Applaudissements]
vingt-six jours de couvaison seront
nécessaires à l'étrange oedicnème avant
que ces poussins ne quittent le nid
sommaire à peine creusé au milieu des
cailloux
quelque chose d'une part de nature
sauvage existe encore ici qui a
quasiment disparu depuis bien longtemps
partout ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
les espèces les plus visibles ont par
exemple pour nom aigrette garzette ou
encore spern pierregarin ces oiseaux
apparaissent les l'arrivée du printemps
de retour d'afrique où ils ont passé
l'hiver les gravières de la basse vallée
du doubs en particulier celle de
fretterans sont le seul site de
reproduction de ces élégantes en franche
comté qui ne compte guère plus d'une
dizaine de couples chaque année les
offrandes traditionnelles et répétées
des mâles de stern à leur future
compagne sont l'habituel façon de
sceller la formation des couples
en retrait de la rivière le paysage
garde également toute sa singularité
ici les vieux saule têtard ont l'air de
monter une garde immuable depuis plus de
100 ans leurs troncs grimace en ont vu
passer à leurs pieds toutes les grandes
crues ses pâturages communaux garde est
également la trace du ligue anciens bras
du doubs d'apparence anodine
ces dépressions ou l'eau reste
prisonnière au printemps cache parfois
un petit secret sur lequel seule la
tombée du jour permet parfois de lever
le voile
tout commence par un étrange concert
lointain et indécis
mais qui se précise dès que l'on
s'approche peu à peu de l'eau
[Musique]
ah ah
hahaha
le chanteur ont pour nom frappe au
calamiteux
inutile d'insister bien longtemps sur le
but du concert on aura deviné que tout
second est évidemment destinée aux
femmes kirov discrètement sur l'ongle de
nuit en nuit
la passion amoureuse de calamite durera
ainsi plusieurs semaines
[Musique]
retour à la lumière pour un rendez vous
haut en couleurs double rendez-vous en
réalité avec un martin pêcheur et un
chevalier guignette ces deux là sont de
grands amateurs des berges terreuse et
déborde et gravières de la basse vallée
du doubs
dans la compétition aux couleurs
éclatantes les martins pêcheurs ont ici
de très sérieux concurrents qu'il voit
arriver chaque printemps avec la même
régularité
ceux là sont le guêpier d'europe
ils appartiennent à une famille répandu
essentiellement en afrique où les
couleurs des oiseaux sont infiniment
plus varié et riche qu'en europe
ceci explique sans doute l'exubérance
coloré de leurs primes âge pour
l'instant l'heure est aux conquêtes
amoureuses comme pour les sternes la
technique du petit cadeau est de mise
chez les guêpiers en échange d'un
insecte savamment offerts chaque
prétendant ainsi le droit de tenter sa
chose une ou deux fois
[Musique]
mais la richesse de la basse vallée du
doubs réside ailleurs encore là où la
nature a une fois de plus conservé une
bonne partie de ces droits là où par
exemple les bras mort existe encore et
sont restés connectés au lit principal
de la rivière contrairement à ce qui
s'est passé pour la lourde
[Musique]
dans ces milieux rester en bon état
biologique les habitats des différentes
espèces de poissons et de l'ensemble de
la faune sont restés quasiment intacte
et leur cycle de vie continue de se
dérouler sans perturbation de plus en
période d'étiage où l'eau se fait plus
rare et surtout plus chaudes
ses bras sont toujours en contact avec
la nappe phréatique du sol ce qui assure
aux poissons des conditions de vie idéal
c'est le royaume des gardons des tanches
des carpes des brèmes des perches ou
autres brochets qui trouve ici toute
l'année à la fois de quoi se nourrir et
se reproduire
d'autres bras sont maintenant totalement
isolé de la rivière tout en restant en
eau c'est le cas d'un des très ancien
lit du doubs sur la commune de petit
noir
il coulait ici il y à 150 ans environ
avant que l'homme ne les cartes du
village
[Musique]
m
là ce vieux doux au mythique nous offre
encore bien d'autres cadeaux les maires
de roseaux les rives buissonnante de sol
des étendues de nénuphars les eaux
libres de différentes profondeurs
toujours alimenté par les nappes du
sous-sol forment une mosaïque de milieux
d'une beauté et d'une richesse
biologique extraordinaire
[Musique]
la liste est longue des habitants du
lieu qui ont tous en commun de préféré
la discrétion du couvert végétal les
rousses roll les hérons pourprés ou
bihoreau les grèves sont par exemple de
ceux-là seuls héron cendré daigne
parfois s'offrir au regard surtout en
période de reproduction où il faut
pêcher sans relâche pour nourrir une
famille lors ni groupe est en colonie de
plusieurs couples sont dissimulés en
hauteur dont l'épaisseur du feuillage
des zones où des grands sol avec les
ronds s'achève pour nous le voyage le
doubs de son côté encore 20 km à faire
avant de se fondre finalement dans la
saône
alors quel sera l'avenir de cette
rivière est surtout celui de la loue le
premier paraît avoir retrouvé ici une
certaine sérénité
ce qui n'est pas le cas dans la partie
haute de son cours
quant à la loue son avenir semble bien
incertain
si le choix est de lui faire retrouver
son lustre d'antan
l'urgence est là devant nos yeux l'heure
est à l'action rapide forte
faisant fi des résistances car ce qui
est en cause
fabienne au delà des poissons et d'une
biodiversité abondante
ici comme ailleurs dans le monde c'est
la pérennité futur de la ressource en
eau qui est en jeu
[Musique]
je